lady gaga devastated after her dear
friend is critically wounded
and two of her beloved dogs are stolen
our lauren zema is on the scene with an
eyewitness
and dramatic new images of this vicious
attack
[Music]
shooting
bullet casings a bloody sidewalk it was
a chaotic scene last night here in
hollywood
as gaga's friend and dog walker ryan
fisher was found
lying on the ground after being shot
with a semi-automatic handgun
as two people stole two of gaga's
beloved french bulldogs
tell me what happened i heard screaming
for a long time
i saw the guy screaming and that's when
i heard the gun shot and a second
gunshot
and then that's when i heard the car
take off
ryan who has posted with gaga's pups
was apparently still clutching one of
her three pooches
miss asia seen here in a blanket being
loaded into a squad car
the other two koji and gustav taken the
guy was fighting with them
and then that's when he wouldn't let go
of the dogs and that's when they shot
him there's so much blood everywhere
this morning i spoke exclusively with
ryan's friend and former client who is
still devastated he would literally lay
his life down for them which
hopefully he did not we heard he moved
to la just to walk
her dogs gaga wanted him pretty much to
herself
the singer's bodyguard picked up miss
asia from the police station
gaga was in rome during the brazen dog
napping and a source tells e.t
she's beside herself horrified
completely devastated and sickened
she feels somewhat helpless in italy but
is praying for ryan
koji and gustav ryan's in the hospital
and recovering
a half million dollar reward is now
being offered for koji and gustav's safe
return
no questions asked a well-bred french
bulldog go anywhere from
10 to 25 000 dog rescuer to the stars
melissa basilar
tells e.t there's a black market for
this breed but she believes
this was a targeted incident did you get
a new french bulldog i did i did gustav
i think that these people 100
knew that they were getting lady gaga's
dogs what's the matter
[Music]